so here's what we've been doing
um we've been doing like and by the way
I'm super high
you want to know something you are too
me too yeah
not not as high as him that's for
sure people ask if we get high
together we don't get high together but
we've been high in the same spot a lot
example hey yeah right now yeah
this is not a Carrie Underwood
song dude I got it
all right
here's what we do
okay uh
are you hitting on me dude
you actually take mushrooms earlier
are you talking about am I high on
mushrooms right now yeah
he's definitely very high on mushrooms
yeah yeah no I didn't take no Heroes
dose you know what I mean but I'm
definitely High yeah I warned you hey by
the way you know what I feel pretty good
that you don't know that I'm hot
I'm doing better than I thought I was
[Applause]
hey don't Circle I feel so much better
about that story I just told the whole
time I was like they could tell I'm so
high
everybody's looking at me right now they
can tell I'm so high
yeah yeah
can you play the guitar can I play the
guitar yeah I'll play guitar okay
um
okay
I like to smoke weed bring it
I like to smoke weed
[Applause]
[Music]